if I get anything from him it's what are
you doing
usually based on someone I'm dating uh
what are you doing
yeah you heard Jennifer Aniston right
her longtime Palin co-star Adam Sandler
has thoughts on her dating life in your
business it all went down Tuesday on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon where Jen
opens up about her decades-long
friendship with the Sandman you've known
each other for years you and Adam over
30 years yeah we met at um we met at
Jerry's Deli on Ventura Boulevard when
we were 20 and 22 but Jen says all those
years as Pals doesn't keep her safe from
a little teasing every now and then I
get anything from him it's what are you
doing
usually based on someone I'm dating uh
what are you doing
I got it
since Jen burst onto the scene in the
90s she's had many high-profile
relationships she was previously married
to Brad Pitt and Justin Thoreau and
dated stars like Tate Donovan Vin Swann
and John Mayer tomorrow I could walk out
of this
hotel and you know meet the man of my
dreams or get hit by bus anything's
possible but right now Jen's focused on
work specifically murder mystery 2 where
she and Adam re-team for the action
comedy sequel set in Paris
bonjour Jen also swung by Good Morning
America where Adam joined her we do love
each other you have fun together it's
been hissed we've been together for over
30 years I know this youngster a long
time and she's just one of the funniest
people I know I do remember when I did
meet you and I remember thinking you
were funny and very uh
filming the latest installment of their
franchise in the city of light meant all
eyes were on the friends star being in
Paris with Jennifer nothing is better
would if you're a famous person because
literally it doesn't matter how famous
you are if Jennifer's there no one's
looking at you the whole place is like
Jennifer
all right
[Music]